I'm Richard I'm one of the producers on
cyberpunk I'm currently working closely
with the level design team and the 3d
assets team and when it came to
cyberpunk and switching from the fantasy
world from The Witcher to this well
world of the future and night city it
was easier due to the fact that many of
our people working with us are huge fans
of the tabletop they played it in the
childhood and they somewhat knew the
world our story team is basically fluent
in cyberpunk and it helped us in the
beginning when we started off with the
project and still helps us through the
production even right now obviously now
team knows what cyberpunk is he knows
the version of what we want to create
with it I mean when it comes to the
switch from TVP to fpp it wasn't really
this decision about a challenge it was a
narrative based decision because we
believe that the fpp camera will allow
us to immerse to play away more into the
story and the environment we are
creating obviously as well we have the
combat sequences which are heavy
shooting focused because of the world in
which niceties taken place and fpp as an
office choice when it comes to those
mechanics Knight city is a condensed
phase of you know heavy skyscrapers
large warehouses on the outskirts and
you have to hold what to quality aspect
which adds footprint sizes right because
you can have one skyscraper with a
footprint of 120 square meters but you
can have 10 floors of that playable so
when it comes to like denser packed
areas in the city like the city center
Watson Heywood
you have community there there if their
routines you can observe them you can
interact with them when it comes to
places where there are not much people
because well it's either too violent in
Pacifica or it's just not inhabited
enough less and sender Domingo you still
have this kind of city flare I mean you
are still feeling you're in the city you
have trash flying around and even if you
think that there is nothing going on
there is something going on you are
never safe tonight City especially when
it's very calm there is something off if
night city is formed and you know that
you have to prepare yourself
myphones we've actually said that night
city is the worst city to live in ever
eh even it was it was built in a bad way
it's just not nice little traffic jams
everywhere so when it comes to
environment yes we want to be as
impressive but when it comes to place
choice and this freedom the player has
he will always feel like the whole city
is open to him he can go wherever he
want at any given moment he can pursue
some many activities on the way and I we
think that this is how we should
approach the topic of creating a
believable world based on the tabletop
but on the other hand providing freedom
to the player I don't want to overuse
this too much but you never know what
might happen and this feeling which will
always be with the player should make
him think about exactly about what he is
doing because everything could have
consequences
we as a player will have the freedom to
modify our body because this is how
cyberpunk works you are doing things to
yourself in order to augment yourself in
order to survive in this very hostile
environment which you are currently in
and therefore certainly the player
himself will come to some ideas and
start thinking that maybe this is a bit
too weird maybe I'll would I do this to
myself if I would be in the game so I
want certainly this topic will be
you know people will be made to think
about it naturally